hey guys my name is Jess McDonald is the
third of June today and you're watching
another episode of games buggies that's
up in things that Jessica things you
might be interested in hearing about the
ps4 1.71 update is now available this
one blessed feature heavy than the
previous update which has people a tad
disappointed but what Sonia promising is
the system software stability during use
of some features has been improved we
haven't heard any specifics on what
features exactly are being targeted for
refinement and even the playstation
support page is yet to incorporate the
update but given this one has a focus on
stability hopefully PS will earn us a
set to see a difference I me know what
PS full features you're still waiting on
Microsoft's Xbox exclusive racing game
for to horizon 2 is coming and we've got
ourselves some brand new images hot off
the presses the screenshots were hosted
on and then removed from IGN but dug up
by near gas and though the games logo
indicates that there certainly from the
title we aren't sure if they're from the
xbox 360 or Xbox one version just yet
then again since they look pretty
further perfect I'd bet on the latter
the game is going to have over 100 cars
and the pictures include our first
glimpses of the 2015 Lamborghini Huracan
and various European setting we've also
received confirmation that xbox fitness
and Sonic & all-stars racing create a
sumo digital is working on the xbox 360
version of the game well playground
games will be handling development on
the Xbox one side get it handling kiss
it the car game and then the game has
been delayed and unfortunately it's not
one of the crap ones batman arkham
knight is the last in a long line of
games to get pushed back and now
sometime next year is the planned
release window the game was supposed to
come out this fall to pc xbox one and
ps4 but Rocksteady Studios has decided
it won't make it stating we just want to
make this the best experience that we
can and that takes time we feel that we
have an absolutely awesome game in the
works and we won
it as great as it possibly can be we
just need more time to do that if we
didn't give the team more time to do it
then we would be releasing something
that we weren't happy with we want to
make sure we're absolutely nailing it
100% Rocksteady also commented on
skipping last generation consoles saying
that the Batmobile experience couldn't
have been properly realized on ps3 or
360 nor would the enormous Gotham City
which is set to be five times bigger
than Arkham City the character models
are also taking advantage of the power
of the ps4 and the xbox one if you want
to get a good look at why the game is
skipping last gen you can check out the
brand new Batmobile centric trailer on
site let me know in the comments if
you're keen for batman arkham knight and
if this trend of delayed games is
worrying you and that's it brought your
news happenings today folks but if you
want more and i bet you will make sure
you come back tomorrow login spa news
bring it can yer